sous la neige nous sommes prêts à faire
revoit les impôts dgi jusqu'à vous les
dalles confiné du printemps dernier
voilà tu souris deviennent les balcons
fille de noël pour répandre l'esprit des
fêtes jusqu'au balcon des années de
heureusement qu l'idée c'est d'aller
vers le public qui est soit mobilité
réduite ou soit carrément confiné alors
que la fin de l'année est assombrie par
les mesures de confinement
ah la la
mère noël accompagné de son âne domino
et de sa lutte et grelotte se sont donné
la mission de colorer le temps des fêtes
des résidents on a choisi des chansons
de noël que tous sont très connus pour
les faire chanter avec nous dans ces
autres cody moins sortir leur bout du
nez
un tube de bonheur dans une journée
c'est l'fun les spectateurs chacun sur
leur balcon joignent leurs voix à celles
des comédiens un cadeau de noël qui n'a
pas pris un bon merci s'était très bien
passée de faire des choses comme ça
c'est une bonne idée merci beaucoup aux
artistes ça ferait du bien
c'est un petit portée pour nous autres
ici marie-eve bégin radio canada
montréal